So I'm taking in a matrix
containing only 0s and 1s.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And what I'm returning is
an integer that represents
the number of violence in our matrix.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Yeah that's perfect really clear.
>> All right thanks.
>> So that was a short but
important portion of the interview.
Can you tell me what
the gentleman was doing?
>> Well, it looks like he's confirming
the signature of the algorithm
he would be writing.
This step is important because now he
knows what's given in the problem.
And what the result needs to be.
This is going to be really useful
information once we get into
the next step.
In a way,
he's also confirming the question again
to make sure he's on the right track.